I'm going to tell you about a new video that
Reason just made.
It's about how to make your own handgun using
some very simple tools
and parts you can buy online.
We're not even going to think about posting
it on YouTube.
So a couple of months ago, after the march
for our lives rally,
YouTube said that they were no longer going
to allow users to post videos
that contain instructions on manufacturing
a firearm.
The video and it's accompanying article are
part of a package of stories
in Reason's Burn After Reading issue.
This includes a bunch of how-tos including
how to bake pot brownies, how to launder Bitcoin,
how to pick the lock on handcuffs and how
to hire an escort.
The whole issue is a celebration of free speech
and our way of documenting how utterly futile
all kinds of prohibitions can be.
The reason we made a video showing how easy
it is to DIY a Glock
is because we wanted to show how the First
Amendment
reinforces and backs up the Second Amendment.
Basically if a bunch of journalists can build
a handgun in their kitchen
we can certainly assume that it will be too
hard
to keep guns out of the hands of motivated criminals.
The question is, once we've made the video,
if YouTube prevents us from uploading it,
have they violated our First Amendment rights?
YouTube of old days was an amazing thing
that's become the digital library of Alexandria
on the internet.
Karl Kasarda is the host of InRangeTV, which
is a weekly YouTube show about guns.
They used to survive on ad revenue until YouTube
started demonetizing content.
Hi, I'm Dennis Prager and welcome to my home.
And last October, the conservative video production
shop Prager University sued YouTube
saying that they had restricted the audience
for their content
and alleging that the company was
"unlawfully censoring its educational videos
and discriminating against its right to freedom
of speech"
Here's the thing, YouTube is a private platform
and there's nothing in the First Amendment
or the Second
that requires them to run our gun video.
Reason can turn down articles for any cause
that we choose.
We can do it because we don't like the color
of the author's hair,
we don't like the font that she used in her
pitch email,
we do not violate a single constitutional
amendment when we do that.
Don't get me wrong I wish that YouTube would
run our video, it's awesome,
but equally awesome is their right and ours
not to run content we don't like.
Right now there are people in YouTube and
in Facebook
and other parts of this oligarchy of corporate
control over the internet
that have decided for whatever reason to use
this concept of community standards
to set fire to books in the library of Alexandria.
Karl Kasarda is right that YouTube is the
closest thing that we have
to the library of Alexandria,
still doesn't mean that they have to run our
video.
Wether you like PornHub or think pornography
is a blight I get that-
Once YouTube made it impossible for Kasarda
to make money on their platform
he just started posting his content to other
platforms, including PornHub.
-psychological perspective, versus, yes, there
might be issues with pornography
depending on your belief system.
Access to the megaphone of your choice is
not a right protected by the Constitution
and YouTube is hardly the first to test this.
In 1972 a teacher's union president who was
running for state legislature
actually sued the Miami Herald
insisting that they run an editorial that
he had written after they attacked him in their pages.
The Supreme Court correctly ruled that ordering
a newspaper to run an editorial
is a violation of the First Amendment.
After all 'a newspaper is more than a passive
receptacle.'
Are you convinced after going through this
long process and digging into the suit
that Google's motives are idealogical?
There is no other possibility-
Prager University argued that YouTube
isn't entitled to the same editorial discretion as the Miami Herald
because it advertises itself as a platform
for free expression
that's committed to fostering a community
where everyone's voice can be heard.
A federal judge, thankfully, dismissed the
Prager lawsuit
rejecting the company's argument that YouTube
is comparable to a government entity
and thus must be open access.
A slew of other judges have arrived at the
same conclusion.
YouTube deserves exactly the same latitude
that those judges gave to the Miami Herald in the 1970s
and that Reason enjoys today.
And that's one of the things that our gun
video is celebrating.
If YouTube doesn't want us to post it to their
site, their loss.
We'll just post it to another platform.
That's what the free and open internet is
about.
So if you want to see our video, you can head
over to Reason.com or PornHub
and see how to make your very own unregistered
firearm.